I'm a very at home and animal so in
Scotland do you own sheep yes and you
commune with the sheep that's putting it
too strongly I walk through the sheep
field you ever walked amongst the
shouting at them yeah but isn't there a
thing with us stream Oh
there usually is okay I've never told
you this but no please
some time back we have at the bottom of
the sheep field there's um there's a
pond where I wash and there's a sauna
would find sauna so we go down there and
get in the sauna but in the summer I
walk to and from with nothing on much
like the Sheep yeah they're appalled
obviously just but one one night that
taught there was a hot summer there was
a kind of will thundering on the door of
our of our place and it's miles away
from anywhere so I thought oh god okay
the man and the maskers come to take us
away and I was there on my own with my
little daughter who was little then in
little nightie and we went downstairs
and opened the door as a massive and
very good-looking policeman outside who
said I'm so sorry to him to interrupt
your evening mrs. Thompson but Tim we've
had reports of an intruder on your land
and and your field and I said really
Oh God when when when was it what was
some time this afternoon a woman was
walking her dog and she saw a 52 year
old man coming naked up through the
Sheep
which point at which point I thought
okay something has happened or my boobs
have dropped so low that from a distance
they read as testicles I nearly whipped
up honestly
[Applause]
[Music]